hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
final season delivered a pretty shocking
turn with Daenerys Targaryen fiery
welcome gift for King's Landing boiler
warning if you aren't cut up yet but
yeah the Khaleesi many of you named your
daughters after it burn the cat of
thousands of innocent people the city
had already surrendered Daenerys could
have just had Cersei escorted directly
into dragon's mouth or aimed drogon
directly at the Red Keep and then you
know maybe killed a few dozen flea
bottom yokels but properly scared oil
tea and everyone else but Danny and
Drogo just went Street by street mopping
up every sad pathetic kid with a sad
pathetic toy in sight many of her own
forces were even caught in the
destruction it was illogical and cruel
and many have said mad yes it would
appear that Daenerys Targaryen has
become the mad queen daughter of the Mad
King every bit as paranoid and sadistic
as he was but frightening Lee actually
capable of following through on her
apocalyptic threats yeah this is
difficult to process considering several
seasons have depicted Daenerys as a more
complex figure capable of rage and
violence but also merciful actively
trying to avoid her father's madness and
aiming to build a better world
so why daddys so mad here is the bitter
truth this turn for Dany is not only
justified by the past trajectory of the
HBO series it's also where George RR
Martin's books are probably headed that
said it's also justified for us to feel
like Danny's madness was out of
character I'm gonna explain why and real
quick new rock star is actually hosting
a live watch party of the finale episode
in an after show this Sunday in New York
though we can debate this stuff in
person tickets are going fast so check
out the link in the description below ok
first let's review the evidence that
Daenerys would go mad like this because
there's actually been a lot of it
episode fives previously on segments
included this audio montage of voices
from the past ringing and Daenerys
azir's as she watched Miss on Days
execution every time a Targaryen is
the quartz flipper coin Mad King gave
his enemies the justice he's a medicine
filled Rinna not their father the attack
you have a gentle heart
garyun Terence you don't wake the dragon
deep these past lines Feud like angels
and devils on Danny's shoulders a tug of
war representing her moral dilemma
it begins with Circe's line it's season
two quoting that coin flip expression
about the unpredictable temperament of
the Targaryen rulers Varys actually
repeated it in the episode but then it
goes to Barristan Selmy in season five
and marine warning Daenerys about her
father's cruelty leading Daenerys to
defend herself saying I am NOT my father
Tyrion echoed that sentiment in the next
line children are not the father he
spoke that to Jon last season a dragon
stone but shortly before that scene
Olenna Tyrell told Daenerys be a dragon
and it was that advice that Daenerys
took when burning the Lannister army and
Randall and dick on Tarly but that
temper is contrasted with the next voice
Jorah Mormont telling Daenerys way back
in season two that you have a gentle
heart the last two lines this montage
were the most ominous first from Maester
Aemon Targaryen he was referring to
multiple lonely Targaryen Zout there
Danny
of course himself but also Jon Snow the
fact that these two Targaryen 's grew up
alone in the world away from each other
now puts him on opposite sides and the
way maester aemon said terrible made us
fear for Danny's state of mind
Emilia Clarke actually stressed Danny
being alone in her big decision moment
was a big part of why she did what she
did and note that the final line of this
whole mental debate came from Danny's
brother Viserys he did the wake the
dragon deep Viserys was always the most
temperamental Targaryen that Danny knew
it's her reaction to his death was the
first glimpse of the darkness inside
Danny he was in a tracking fire cannot
kill a dragon
next Danny resorted to dark magic to try
to save Khal Drogo but when that didn't
work to any burned Mirri Maz derp alive
and the fire rises in season two and
Qarth she used her dragons to burn the
warlock in the house of the undying
and she entombed sorrows on Doc Sousa
live in the vaults and this was after
she warned these members of the thirteen
we will take back what was stolen from
and destroy those who wronged me we will
lay waste to armies and burn cities to
the ground maybe he should have listened
Daenerys his fiery rage grew and grew in
season three she acquired the unsullied
by essentially tricking krasna
Sebastopol burning him alive and
ordering the unsullied to turn on their
masters and torching that city and then
after conquering young Kai and marine
she once again used fire executing a
marine nobleman then advised oath rack
in season six she burned alive the
Dothraki calls and he served control
over the full Dothraki forces and then
she returned to Meereen and used her
dragons to torch the slavers and their
ships so that was six seasons of fire
foreshadowed but in small doses
really each CHIKARA's moment for
Daenerys felt like a climactic release
of a hero surprising her enemies by
unleashing a secret inner power like
Bruce Banner saying that's my secret
emoji but to be honest over time it
became clear that jerk Aras was kind of
Daenerys his go-to move like we get it
you're always angry it's not really a
secret anymore
meanwhile her efforts to show mercy
justice and diplomacy didn't really work
out too well
Daenerys thought a gentler approach
would work better in Westeros than add
in Essos but she only found herself
increasingly isolated and less respected
leading to her to snap and lash out like
this now a lot of critics are blaming
the show's writers for betraying
Daenerys his ark as it was in George RR
Martin's precious books but Martin
himself has indicated this is
essentially where the book version of
Daenerys is headed to so why wouldn't we
watch this does Daenerys madness still
feel weird well before I continue thanks
to rise of the Kings for sponsoring this
episode
rise of the Kings is a war strategy
mobile games set in the Middle Ages but
with fantasy elements thanks again with
Thrones I assume real medieval history
was actually filled with dragons hey you
weren't there you can't prove me wrong
we may question Daenerys for using the
dragon to torch a city but it's pretty
sweet to see a dragon Drakkar as the
lich and rise to the Kings I don't see
any victims so I don't feel bad
rise to the Kings features a bunch of
hero options with varying stats styles
features and beautifully done artwork
now building up the heroes involves a
formation of troops and the promotion of
attributes but it looks long I got
and it's a sure I someone should tell
the people of King's Landing that
actively being on fire is no excuse not
to look fierce you'll also experience
what it's like when your castle is being
attacked so if you had some notes for
the poor victims of King's Landing you
can control your own intricate defense
strategy and rise the king's rise the
King says global server is you can
compete with players from all over the
world you can also set up your own
alliance chat with friends from around
the globe and get to waging war together
so what are you waiting for word
download right for the Kings now using
our download link in the description
below you can also get a free gift pack
with our unique code also in the
description
okay back to Daenerys is madness I
really think that the unnies many of us
are feeling comes down to this for years
we have seen Daenerys as a hero that we
root for that we want to see succeed
when it turns out her character arc is
actually one of a tragic hero so if you
look at any famous tragic hero
Shakespeare's Macbeth Walter White from
Breaking Bad Michael Corleone a flawed
character rises in power doing some
questionable things along the way but we
still kind of root for them and then
about midway through their journey they
finally achieve their crown and it feels
great but maybe a false victory because
their tragic flaw persists and it
corrupts them it descends them into
madness and paranoia about losing their
power so in order to keep their claws in
their power they commit horrendous
crimes until they finally lose that
power and they die usually so tragic
heroes or cautionary tales you aren't
supposed to continue to root for them
unless you want to be that guy fine but
you don't name your kids after that with
Game of Thrones some critics have
complained about things like pacing at
the showrunners shouldn't have tried to
cram these final two seasons and 13
episodes but over 13 hours of
entertainment is plenty of time to tell
a complete story really the people who
make this show are restricted by their
own structure because Game of Thrones
isn't just an Eris's story it's also
John's story
Cersei story Arya story Tyrion story
branches story so if Daenerys sacked
King's Landing immediately upon our
return to Westeros as she probably
wanted to do yeah we would have had time
to see her collapse over the final two
seasons it would have worked as a good
tragic story but then the show would
have just been her story they needed to
keep things balanced among several
different characters so instead the
battle for the throne would be laid to
the final battle which unfortunately
left us with no real time for falling
action or
recalibration so Daenerys the story
proceeded forward as any hero's journey
but before she reached her goal she
descended into irredeemable madness so
we felt this whiplash because within a
single episode we had to adjust into
accepting we're actually watching a
different kind of story one following a
tragic hero here that we should judge
and pray for their punishment it's a lot
to do in a small amount of time so yeah
Daenerys is a mad Queen but angry mad
and she has every right to be furious
despite not wanting to be your father to
be queen of the ashes every attempt she
made to take the noble path robbed more
and more away from her she lost Vaziri
on ragel Jorah Mormont Masson day half
her Dothraki and unsullied forces her
entire fleet she felt isolated and then
on top of that he got very teary and
John everybody betray me I'm fed up with
this world bat my pipe I know
burning the women and the children
there's no reason to do that but if you
look at this through Daenerys his eyes
her desperate isolated eyes she sees her
situation as no hope for her to inspire
love from the people of Westeros she has
only been effective when she inspires
fear she said that her plan was to erase
the old order root and stem and start
fresh with the next generation Massey is
our strength our mercy towards future
generations he will never again be held
hostage by a tyrant yeah it's a truly
nihilistic outlook and really a
hypocritical one because that's a tyrant
calling a time retirement but this is a
really interesting debate to get into if
we weren't so confused over what kind of
story we were watching really every
story should do what this is trying to
do create a moral debate among us over
whether a character's actions are
justified but that said basic clarity
over the characters motivations should
not require a previously on Prieta sewed
callback montage and post episode
interviews with the cast and crew so I
get the frustration but I am optimistic
eventually well hopefully george RR
martin will release his final two books
of the series the winds of winter in the
dream of spring which will have
thousands of pages with which to
empathize with Dany's and her thoughts
and her tragic descent and maybe after
the finale of the show on HBO and some
time to process at all Danny's tragic
fall in these final seasons will look a
lot clearer from a distance look and
even a great series is not easy
and I think we should still be floored
that an epic story of this scale and
magnitude exists for our enjoyment and
for us to pull it apart so yeah I got
questions but ultimately I'm super
grateful and I'm gonna continue to
devote my energy to appreciating this
experience but I wouldn't know what you
guys think about this comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA boss
subscribed into rock stars and again if
you live in the new york area you can
join us for our live finale watch party
and have to show this sunday details in
the description and yeah to those who
named your loved ones after fictional
characters whose stories are still being
told you might now regret it for a whole
other reason than it being super basic
[Music]